despite the American right wing claiming
that the left is indoctrinating children
through critical race Theory and
left-wing university courses it is
actually the right wing that is
indoctrinating children now we have this
recent example from Florida where Ron
DeSantis and the Florida Board of
Education banned and an advanced
placement every time I see AP I think
Associated Press banned an advanced
placement black history course because
they claim that it contains queer Theory
and indoctrination and things that
should not be in such a course now
yesterday I talked to you about how
absurd this is and the fact that this is
not a required course this is actually
it's not even elective it's an elective
advanced placement course and if you
think about it as a college equivalent
college courses regularly have more
Niche topics of interest to the people
that want to take the course you don't
have to take it anyway it was all absurd
but this is an example of the right
claiming we are are working very hard to
stop the left from indoctrinating our
kids but the reality is that the
propaganda of child indoctrination is
overwhelmingly from the right here is
the latest propaganda being promoted by
Mike Huckabee this was this came on
during a commercial break on Fox
Business it is promoting the kids guide
to fighting socialism which you can get
at socialism stinks.com we've spoken
before about the president Trump kids
guide from it looks like the same
organization because Huckabee promotes
it and like the font looks the same this
is the free kids guide to president
Trump which will allow children to learn
about President Trump's accomplishments
in office president Trump's vision for
America and how president Trump's
policies are right for America this is
straight up for kids okay this is not
the type of thing I want to teach kids
which is here's how you think for
yourself
here's how you can determine whether you
are reading something that is true or
false that's what I want to teach kids
okay that's not what the Trump kids
guide for children teaches them in 2017
the Trump Administration proposed
cutting funding for after-school
programs that provided a safe and
positive environment for children and
instead they redirected that money to
religious organizations and groups that
promote conservative value that is the
right funding the rights indoctrination
of children but they say it's the left
that doesn't
in Texas the State Board of Education
has promoted a conservative agenda in
state schools They promoted the teaching
of creationism the downplaying of the
role of slavery in the Civil War to
children that is right-wing
indoctrination of kids in Arizona the
State Board of Education approved a
curriculum that promotes a conservative
pro-trump agenda and it downplays the
contributions of minorities and
marginalized groups in American history
in Idaho a school board member promoted
the teaching of Bible courses in public
school and said we should be teaching
creationism alongside evolution in West
Virginia the State's Department of
Education promoted a conservative agenda
in public schools including promoting
coal mining and downplaying the role of
climate change in their educational
standards I'll give you one more example
in Oklahoma
State Board of Education promoted a
conservative agenda and approved
textbooks that present a conservative
perspective on American history and on
government they say the left
indoctrinates children they are actually
the ones that do it so
what is it that we can do
all the things we talk about right
you've got to be involved with school
boards you've got to be involved with
education issues at the local state and
federal level and we have to fight
against the idea that teaching kids
critical thinking is liberal
indoctrination and this is something
that is unfortunately becoming
widespread when you talk to
conservatives many not all when you talk
to some conservatives and say we should
really be teaching critical thinking
when kids are 10 11 12. we should be
teaching media literacy we should be
doing all these things many of these
right-wingers say that's liberal
indoctrination but of course it's not
the the reality though is that if more
kids knew how to think for themselves if
more kids knew how to think critically
if more kids knew how to
um suss out whether messages they are
being given in the media are true or
false or are trying to convince them of
something that isn't true
it is true that it would hurt the
conservative movement Fox News relies on
having an uninformed audience where they
turn on the TV and Tucker Carlson says
see this floating space vagina which is
just a cloud you should be scared of
that and then the audience goes yeah I
should whereas an audience that is more
media literate and that is more
well-versed in critical thinking
wouldn't fall for that so I've mentioned
this before we are very very close to
publishing a kids book on critical
thinking this is going to be quite
literally an illustrated children's book
I've been saying for years and years and
years there need to be better materials
and more materials for teaching kids
this stuff early we are doing it uh we
are almost done with the uh text of the
book we are trying to get the
illustrations finalized and set up the
printing of the book Etc we are sort of
putting our money where our mouth is and
we are going to be publishing such a
book it's going to be fantastic a couple
people already reached out and said
David when you do this I'm buying 100
copies and I'm gonna send send them I'm
going to bring them to libraries in my
area this is super super exciting and
I'm glad to be doing it and I'll have
more information for you about it very
very soon